what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to jack harlow on a
chicken shop date i keep hearing about
the internet like obsessing over jack
harlow so i just want to see what this
is about because
i like don't know who he is uh before i
start don't forget to subscribe to the
channel bring that notification bell
that way you're going to be notified of
my daily videos also go to my instagram
and send me some clips of stuff you want
me to react to if i don't respond right
away i just like send me a couple
messages i'll see it um because i've
been kind of winding down on like clips
i need to react to
um
okay i'm gonna start
what's poppin
good start
[Music]
so i went to your show last night you
were there yep
did you not see me i didn't see you i
was waving at you okay
i believe you i didn't see
what was the gut there was a guy at the
front and she had a sign what did it say
[ __ ] me
oh that escalated so quickly so
what's your type
my type
he's got a juice box dark hair
you know what i like yeah
where i'm from i don't know if they have
it out here they have little
boxes in public you can open them up and
there's little books inside it's a
little library yes take a book put it
back
never done it i just like walking past
them can you read
do you
what the hell is this
do you sorry i meant do you like to read
i do okay you see how he's giving her
like banter like that's what women like
like we like banter because he's
treating her like she's a human like
that was a dumb question
i heard that your weakness is for girls
born in the 70s that's true i was just
wondering like what about the 90s
is that i like the 90s cool
but something about the 70s
yeah
well
what about it well
you are stupid
i'm stupid yeah like in a good way
what's this
rambina ribena do you like it it's
delicious
[Music]
first one and i had my first lucazoid
the other day leukazoid the orange drink
the leukazoid lucazade
[Laughter]
like
stuff like that it's like a manchester
thing what do you say again instead of
really
or at the end
this is an odd date i i don't know how
to feel about it or something
do a whole sentence of something oh that
was quite good quiet yes no no yeah it's
quiet quiet no yeah
how are the wings
oh the wings
quite exceptional
a bit of spicewood they're alright
what's your best chat up line oh
hi
is that undefeated
you know what else is undefeated this is
what the black pill would be like chad
the chads they can always just do
nothing and get girls
hi i'm jack you're shaking
emma yeah don't start this [ __ ] again
i saw you hang out with h
hmm
he's one of my exes
i've heard
yep that's why i came in here a little
bit reserved we're good friends
i'm trying to keep it that way for y'all
okay
cool i love h i know he loves you he was
telling me all about you really what did
he say wild [ __ ] no he didn't there's
nothing to say i'd be seeing him under
your pictures too oh yeah
he's obsessed with me
spending time with somebody else and i
get to wishing that she was you
any girl could be beautiful but not any
girl can just be in tune
and you so until you understand me
i make you laugh and you say to me that
you can't stand me you soul food and you
eye candy i want to meet you in miami
and i want you to meet my family
okay well i'll just check my schedule
and see if i can
but i probably can
what this is weird i don't know how to
feel what like is that that was a clever
rhyme though nice romantic thing for
someone
i bought them a plane ticket was it
private jack no no
economy 58c
like i was doing absolutely nothing like
he's not trying to impress this [ __ ]
have you reached peak cuteness yet no i
know you're still getting cuter by the
hour
you are funny
i know um i think i got like four years
to feed four years okay and then
did you have braces as a child i did so
did i really yeah i don't know they did
those over here
well
what you got next what you got for me
next
how many children do you want many many
all girls really yeah i want eight
daughters is excessive
okay it's my answer and where would you
live would you live in a big house with
them london oh you live in london
on oxford street eight daughters
single dad and you'd be like wrapping
around town
when i have kids i want the opposite i
want boys i don't really care but i want
if i could pick i'd have boys and the
reason being is because i want a
basketball team i want five boys and i
want them to be the starting five at the
high school so that way if they have a
trash coach i can just make them run
plays from the sidelines and what are
they gonna do
bench your entire starting five i don't
think so
still wrapping around town
would you ever move to london for a girl
for a girl yes okay yes
yes can you cook no oh
not to worry can you no ah to worry
i need to pee
by all means don't let me stop you
i'm just gonna bob i'm gonna wait is
that your outro you better get up and go
take a bit of the piss
take a bit of the
piss oh my gosh this is like
i need to read the comments on this
this gentleman is what we call confident
but not cocky
i'm a grown-ass man giggling at this
dude flirting he's literally the boy in
english class you're obsessed with
because he's oh my god girls love him
look at this
he's got to be one of the most
charismatic celebrities i've seen in a
while
[Music]
um jack you're stupid her i'm stupid
jack no like in a good way we all
understood
oh my gosh i feel like that man will not
simp
um
let me know if you guys like these type
of reactions and don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and send me
clips on my instagram what you want me
to react to next time i'll talk to you
guys later